is he/she Mizzou's we're in nice and
early this morning I'm with an early
riser I'm joined by George Barnes who is
the co-founder of Hamilton Barnes
morning by the way you have got the name
from and basically George as I'll just
say and we're we're always always like
to start thanks for coming in firstly
Roger oh she gave me a lift that's the
first time anyone's done that yeah
appreciate that and B yes so we're
always like to start is how how did you
get into the mad world of recruitment
how did that happen the very mad world
of recruitment so yeah a bit more funny
story actually so left school school
wasn't really for me yeah in the sense
that I think it schools fantastic if you
want to go to university sure what's
driving those do you want to become a
lawyer you want to throw something very
specialist yeah but I went to school and
I just wasn't engaged yeah in any way
shape or form yeah I found that school
was sometimes quite slow yeah I pick
things up quick and then you know you'd
be waiting for the rest of the class is
developing and all that kind of stuff so
left school with you know medium grades
yeah I'd say start it off so the first
actually off I'll take it back a step
longer heard of a charity called City
Gateway okay that are based in East
London which is where I'm from
yeah got on a basically a scheme steal
an NVQ in personal training okay bit
random a lot better looking them
basically did the mvq which which was
really really good see go away great
cherries mcawesome and basically got a
job working in a gym yeah LA Fitness in
Leadenhall Street okay so started off
this is why is it school just after an
hour and I'll see a personal story now
quite quickly learn the same basically
the salespeople work there's the money I
want the people that you have put
training nice of the salespeople that
worked in the gym selling remember like
memberships okay
and I was a little bit unsure initially
but they were looking for salespeople so
I did some personal training for about
six months so then I was like oh they
salespeople that I have on you know they
have a good laugh and but you ever seem
to get into sales and no no I just yeah
I never you know I like people I've
always liked people
he's quite confident like talk when
you've gone out talk to people and all
that yeah yeah yeah and I think
particularly the personal training you
have to go it's people on the gym court
mate cells
yeah and my first manager there chuckle
Chris Welch yeah he said you should do
it sure because I think the thing was
basically we I was working this personal
trainer
they had a sales role yeah the role
didn't work out as a sales person they
were gonna backfill my personal training
role i wouldnt have a job yeah yeah it's
on and then and I just thought you know
I'll do it
so did it that was really really good
fun but I think the the frustration for
me yeah and what I also like about
recruitment is every single month you
start on zero yeah sales but when you
work in in the gym you're dependent upon
inbound sales some people walking into
the gym selling memberships you notice
them or going out in the street it was
as raw as getting people's phone numbers
Wow outside the train station training
ground for yeah right exactly so you
stand that side Fenchurch Street Station
really on paper trying to get people's
phone numbers Oh tough you off of it now
I've got a lot better yeah it's tougher
than it yeah very it was a lot before I
had a similar thing but my experience
was them will call it me or cup it was
magaluf and I ended up working there
abroad there for two years running and
before that again I went to school
college and I was the last year college
but then it was was in did you not go to
college yeah I did like a few months
yeah and then you were like now yeah so
I did I did free as a college and cuz I
still have no idea what I wanted to do
the last year actually did hear plumbing
yeah and so I still had no idea wanted
to do so just didn't hot job was yeah I
was just doing the
the normal full time I think what was I
doing before I went away delivering
pizzas at Domino's that's awesome yeah
and then when abroad and basically I
landed myself with your pretty pretty
similar where I basically I had to UM
sell tickets for an event and I made no
money unless I sold tickets I've got ten
euros per ticket it's pretty decent
never done it before absolutely [ __ ] my
pants
every time I sagat's people because I
leash had to stop people in the street
and say work Toronto conversation and
give him a pitch and I was so bad at it
at the start yeah but by that by the
time I went home I was decent and I was
like alright so it sells is sells is
what I'm up for so and I can definitely
relate to that I start yeah there's very
few people that go through the education
system even aware of sales as a career
mmm but full stop which offering
frustrates me I know in my opinion
everything is sales yeah so I mean like
you have to sell yourself on a daily
basis
yeah to whoever that is even if it's
just like having and trying to build
friendships or relationships with people
like you have to follow your mom but you
play out yeah or whatever
yeah literally anything light so yeah I
can't agree more so you did that fair
play to doing that guitar so you did how
long do you do that for a year okay um
then a lot talking to people like doing
sales I joined a few guys up to the gym
that funny enough work for s3o which is
natural because we were based on
Leadenhall Street yeah walk tells
offices what on Leadenhall Street which
are around it yeah and whenever you know
he's got a story to achieve they're
really good guys got along with him
really really well yeah always up for
having a laugh yeah they was coming
really late so I neither worked hard
gym at like quarter nine yeah so get
chatting to them always have a chat with
them when they're in there helped a lot
in the gym floor I've basically just
said mickey out from everybody she
laughs and then one of them James to
meet you
in still work to work something real in
the US now he said if he ever thought
get into recruitment and I was like oh
that's it hear that mate I was like what
he's like all that sort of a job getting
people jobs and he was like very honest
eight men so I was like it's very many
years ago
this what meeting is obligate yeah and
he basically explained to me gave me an
analogy of you've got you know ex person
he used the analogy of a personal
trainer so Jim approaches you because
they're looking for a personal trainer
what you do you can even go out and find
the personal trainers using XYZ yes yes
or you get a really good personal
training you ring around all the gym
strung up a job so pretty Sedona
and I got it I was like that's good he
then put me in contact with my now
business partner Nick Barker who was
director walk teletón yeah Nick was in
the process of leaving also after he was
futures s3 or tell for years yes yes
obviously their that the success they
had and the things were changing and
kind of wanted to start something new so
I interviewed for Nick when he just
joined John recruitment who it was at
the time and it was a perfect time to
gain because it was Nick my memories bit
patchy what maybe one or two other
people in the office max I really yeah
up in Holborn that's where the first
offices were start yeah but they had a
map they have an office in Manchester
with 50 people are I've ever started up
London yeah and I so the chap that owns
it John
he they'd worked to give her computer
futures John gone off for the start Jam
many years before yeah but had never
gone off to really like a London
operation yeah go for it okay so Nick
was looking perfect she come up and yeah
unbelievable great company really really
good company so how many years you said
that so you join them um you join them
yeah yeah a real solid length of time in
your first of equipment all right which
I think really helps doesn't it in terms
of giving that ground in that foundation
to whatever you end up there 100% yeah
and I think it that was all down to Nick
really I think a lot of people join
recruitment businesses and because the
leaders they work for a very stressed
very high strong and natural they've got
pressure yeah yeah maybe the balls
getting pressure to hit targets et
cetera et cetera
Nick took all that pressure off the
whole office I love that Nick was
walking around really stressed by even
I think sigh Billa no no so he was
managing director a contract and I think
I think what that allowed to do is the
people beneath Nick re me I never at any
point thought I was gonna get sacked and
that's the biggest thing isn't the fear
and the stress how why did you why did
you not think that we're doing well
though right what I was doing deals yeah
don't get me wrong and probably for the
first year I was good okay he was right
I was good I wasn't amazing I wasn't
rubbish I was good and and I think back
and partly the reason what I wanted what
I do on my business yeah is I don't ever
want anybody to feel like they're gonna
get sacked yeah well every eight foot if
you're working hard
I'll look after you yeah I'll always
look after you because you need coaching
in the Train that's my fault yeah if
you're struggling and you're working
hard it's my fault yeah basically our
need to help you know well uncover that
because I think I think that that's the
money it's that's more of a mindset that
you're talking about that you're you're
willing to take complete accountability
and you're not willing to point the
finger yes I think is the right thing to
do isn't it so I guess what I'm always
interested in and always luck to us so
you said you was good in those early
days but like how difficult were those
first twelve months because for me I
think now look what only one and free
people stay longer and we're only one
and free people stay longer than 12
months in recruitment yeah yeah and I
think a big factor that is what goes on
in those first 12 months obviously yeah
so what how was that first 12 so you
said that you never fellow who's gonna
gets out which I was he helped really
good yes he didn't I'll get you
everything in like enormous pressures
and those sorts of things you had a bit
more freedom and yet those just so how
were those first twelve months for you I
thought about leaving quite a lot yeah I
did yeah
because have loads of [ __ ] days in a row
am i doing literally like I think it was
about three or four put about three or
four weeks ago what is a moment nearly
quit them 180 quit so there was a some
Eifert my first placement was complete
by fluke
yeah the guy that I placed I had comment
I run him on a Saturday yet hitman I was
in the office on a Saturday love that
right and I run him on a Saturday and
the candidate I run wasn't looking but
their friend had
at five years before but was looking to
get but said you out retirement what I
was like what those one of those stories
I'm not sure about the client was
Volkswagen sort of vacancy I'm sorry we
didn't permanent contract okay Coco I've
brought in through contract but at the
time because because of the market in
the way the financial crashing yeah it
just wasn't conducive and the chap that
I place the place of a Volkswagen yeah
which is the random customer to pick up
the first place with Volkswagen and he
was commuting two hours well half so it
was computed commuting from Newark to
slough every well not in him well and
the only reason he did it is he wanted
to get over time and he basically just
looking into some extra money yeah and
Volkswagen game a car on a fuel card on
ice free travel well and he based it was
on a lot in the car anyway I caught a
listen to music get up early and last I
checked I don't quote me on this on
LinkedIn he's still there love that God
you buzzing you think you're really good
yeah and then you think every place and
that's what kind of place would be like
that kind of peak you're really really
good Midas Touch everything's all going
really really well
yeah my next placement drops out yeah so
you offer them you got did you get a
camera for done I just didn't tell me Oh
literally I've done the placement yeah
accepted sign the contract competitor
literally over the road great I'm still
if such we can it now he could go yeah
and we will put that behind us many
years and he took the job accepted it
signed the contracts due to start
running really really good really full
starting just didn't turn off first Wow
then once yeah luckily it wasn't great
with the obviously the Klein because
they didn't use agencies very often
either mmm but I managed to flip them
into a customer nice love that so what
so what what Pierre was there anything
that lets you you you had to look in the
mirror and be like well now I've got a
carry on so like what was there was a
moment where you nearly quit in those
first time months or was it I thought
I think it was a lot of little bumps all
the time there's a lot of colors
constantly up and down up and down it's
it's one of these things right so the
whole concept of recruitments quite a
hard thing to get your head around and
if you've never done it yeah and it's
just you've gone from when I was in the
personal trainer I knew what was doing
yeah and then you go I'm working and she
don't you do it yeah to a certain degree
you get your training you get obviously
your development but there's nothing
that can prepare you for when you're on
the firing and the client says one thing
and you go yeah that's what I think that
that's I think that's what those 12
months before though isn't it yes
essentially those 12 months yeah that's
what I mean like you can do all the role
plays you can do the training you talked
about like you that the best way that
lasts how my other rights have got me to
learn those on the phones the first day
and but just speak into candidates and
then again it would be learning as to
like--how'd
but as soon as you do with one scenario
you're then best equipped to then deal
with that in the future do you not I
mean I think that that's why I'm those
12 months I think that if you're in a
business where if they're if they're
just encouraged to take the right
actions and do the right things and
you're not worried about [ __ ] hounding
my targets whatever then they have a lot
better chance of staying longer and
being more successful
yeah what was your training like then
what so what sector did you what sector
was that exactly I do now sort computer
networking all right that's good yeah
you get training on the sector because
you said that you didn't really know
what you're doing but you said I used to
learn from the candidate so I basically
I joined yeah
and Nick was like so you'll be the first
person to die - yeah Jam they did
engineer in HR headed up the IT that is
basic you do IT yeah go away do some
research this weekend have a think about
what you want to do in IC and thanks so
I sat down and I think about it I looked
online I'm gonna look around and
obviously RIT is a massive space but I
think what I liked about computer
networking is that it particularly Cisco
which is the market leader in computer
networks okay they have certifications
that would tell you as a recruiter what
this person is specializing in to what
level their gradient line
CCNA ccnp CTIA CC re top CCMP there's no
there's no [ __ ] in that like that's
yeah study materials got a lot better so
people can get certifications know what
skills in it yeah but I looked at it and
I thought like Microsoft every single
person I see we've got Microsoft like
they've got a couple of certifications
you try to look for a niche someone
different and that was the thing I think
particular I wanted to I wanted to pick
something that other people weren't
really doing and they were smart yeah
the tech that technology powers the
internet yeah getting bigger and bigger
at the time yeah and it still is and
when I first started out I was like
right so I've got this guy he wants lot
basically 70k got CCNA that doesn't
really make any sense and you can kind
of piece the bits together if you don't
know what you're looking for which when
you start you don't you research and
obviously ask people questions yeah I
found it was quite good asking
candidates yeah you've learned them that
was but that wasn't my next question
because the advantage I have was I was
an insurance and I'm real quick than
insurance yeah so that really helped me
but yes sir but there's there'll be a
lot of people out there that go into an
industry that they might just be
slightly interested in or they want to
get into recruitment and they ended up
in a set to which they know nothing
about so I guess I'm sure you have
people now that join your business that
don't know anything about what you're
talking about so what's your advice for
people to the best way to get skilled up
as quickly as possible in that in the
sets of their recruiting for and so what
I found is quite good so initially when
I joined I bought Cisco Networking for
dummies okay so actually do the legwork
and actually learn about so you have to
do it yeah if you want to sound credible
with senior stakeholders make such a
difference and particularly as well
recruitment gets a bad rap yeah because
a lot of people join in and leave and a
lot of people's recruitment experience
is of somebody that's got free four
months experience that hasn't done the
legwork
yes you have to do it like more more
than anything you'll get experience over
time and the pieces will click together
yeah over time but it's just being able
to understand kind of how it hangs
together and it'll give you a
competitive edge there's a lot of life
you like again I reckon you'll have more
of an idea than me cuz you're you now
employ people through a business but if
you if you generally when you start if
you spend X amount of hours each week
learn about your sector I guarantee you
Maggiore or P your competitors aren't
doing that do you not I mean it's a lie
it will give you a competitive once if
you generally do really understand their
world and you can pick up on certain
keywords and those sorts of things and
as you said it it builds that
credibility when you when you're on it
definitely helped when I really
understood insurance innocent
credibility for sure because candidates
and clients velara okay there's this
disguise she understands what we do and
what we're talking about helped you
stick a lot on you liking your first job
because obviously yeah I mean yeah as in
100% I think it just helped me it helped
a hug with my confidence I think when I
was speaking to people yeah which helped
and then I think and yeah I think people
always said to people that I understand
I understand your world I understand
what you do and I think that that
matters because I'm sure there's a lot
of recruiters out there who had just
focused on if they have the right skills
and not focused on if they actually
understand that person and if you
actually understand the sort of
challenges that come with their job yeah
there's a lot more to relate to and
there's a lot more to understand and you
can actually draw on certain points
which you can then use to say well I've
got this company that actually that that
won't be a challenge then they can help
you with that you go I mean I thought
that would that will help a lot I think
one understand I think there's a few
pointers for for people as well I think
we we have technical people come in and
the workshops with our consultants on
which is awesome
like what animate some clients you've
got on with four years yeah and you
explain the you explain the benefit in
them
also it would only be an hour's
investment from them but if they're
means on the flip side that the
consultants got to find better people
and the conversation can be more
credible yeah you have to do that and
also the end of the month me and a few
the guys in the team are going to Cisco
live in Barcelona I think I saw your
person yeah
so we're basically that that's a massive
massive massive s Expo they run once a
year where basically everybody from the
whole of Europe they do one in the u.s.
one in Europe and everybody from the
whole of Europe goes there and we're
gonna be doing all the technical
sessions as well really because we want
to see what it's about
obviously I've tempered it or not all
right yeah but what I want to see so
what experience the engineers have how
does it work yeah like like you
explained it to be break it down for me
yeah but you know the people that we
work with at Cisco well obviously be
dealing with really highly technical
people but
I'll be like we're not technical but
explain to me what's the benefits of it
yeah how does it work
I think that I think that's great and I
think we we used to we used to get
involved in those sorts of things and
insurance and I think the end of the day
if I'm account if I'm if I'm someone
who's looking for a job and I'm speaking
to someone who I can tell is actually
and enthusiastically trying to
understand my world I'd rather work with
something like that I mean so I think if
you're just sitting there just worried
about getting placements and just
worried about getting numbers on the
board and those sorts of things I think
again it comes down to having a
competitive advantage I think that if
I'm speaking to a recruiter who I feel
like is just focused on getting me a new
job or focused on helping me get any job
but also actually having a real interest
in what I do like I know who I'm gonna
probably have a better experience with
you know I'm in so and so how did the
next couple years go them do you get
into management whether you just
continue getting better or what what was
the the journey so um basically started
off doing 360 from day one yes I don't
recommend that I think it's the best
approach yeah I just did candidates for
brass six months yeah which I think
perfect resource of that into year 60 I
think is best
so the 360 and then basically was
pulling more jobs than I could fill
which is a good thing peaks of a
specific area mapped out the customers
went after it you know that good
structured structured way and yeah then
basically started hiring a team
initially is kind of resource er tight
like so when did you start managing so
you have to get people under yeah yeah
really big year yeah okay
I'm quite quickly yeah they were thorak
lot like in the sense that it was you
push today or did you like I like I like
helping people yeah and I get along
particularly so James who still works me
now yeah which is good he's just in New
Zealand I'd be on a nice timing what is
that jammed in Joe's dead because he
reached out to me yeah did he yeah yeah
about the podcast instead a decent write
name he was on your first hires he was
my first fire and he stayed with you
still gonna love that
yeah so yeah and then um for me it
wasn't necessarily about managing people
it was about making abandon
people that all get on and I like teams
and I like yeah even like last week my
team had already come on of the closet
well that's what it is it works for me I
have a really good week and I wouldn't
come here and we just all hugged like
this is weird I thought you loved it I
love that that's just the way I am I'm
really really invested in my teams and
people and it was just like the kind of
natural progression okay so I guess as
you said because you started this some
hole was set to from scratch you would
end up getting a lot of jobs and it only
made sense why I got jobs I've had
someone just dedicated to finding people
for these jobs yeah you're gonna
obviously grow the desk and grow that
part of the business right yeah yeah
okay cool so when I guess and then did
you do that for the next three years
just continuing to build that team or
bill bill bill
you always bill yeah okay yeah all right
so how how how was that challenge or
foreign people then what did you learn
free that cuz I'm sure you had some bad
ones in there maybe other night but that
what did you try and account for in a
recruiter was it all non experienced
people that yeah so what did you tend to
gravitate towards to make sure that they
had to I think I think particularly it
was like key drivers and goals like I
need the people that join I want to have
like a clear plan around what it is they
want to achieve in in their personal
life yeah must be clear not in their
work on yeah what you want to achieve in
your personal life because obviously
what's motivating them
yeah what's motivating you like where
are you going I want to see that them I
thought oh cool and that they thought
about yeah also as well I want to see
that when I meet them I want to see if I
get on with them because straightaway
oh that's quite easy to say that but
when they meet a client or they meet a
candidate or whatever when they speak to
P but a lot of time you bring out people
but no off you but they don't know you
and you have no relationship with them
you have to be able to build rapport
with them quite quickly hmm and I want
to know that when I walk into the
interview I'm a really really friendly
interviewer yeah but I want to know that
I can walk away feeling a little fuzzy
does that make sense what you mean like
you know you like so you know sometimes
like I met a chap the other way yeah a
candidate
and straightaway took a lot through 100%
their guidance things Joan about Jan's
trust I'm recruitment I think it's
partly because he was smiling at me the
whole time even though he's already
smiling at me yeah Radio definitely and
he listens and the points he made were
like really really credible yeah and he
was just really polite and really nice
yeah I love that and I was like yeah
you're a people person straightaway yeah
but then sometimes like I'll speak to
people or I might meet somebody over
straightaway because actually gets my
back up straightaway yeah say something
couldn't use go
no not sure yeah yeah straight way so
for me the experience I get the
experience that I assumed they would
then project when they do the job that's
fair enough yeah that's fair enough so
okay so let's fast forward a bit then so
and you didn't then he left there what
four years down down the road so how
long did you work on recruitment before
you set your own agency yeah yeah for
four and off years all right okay so
then you went to another company yeah I
wouldn't sell have a comment I went to
another company for nine months okay
which just for me like at the time I
know in hindsight I wanted to start my
own company bar but I've been in
recruitment for years yeah
are you some dreams about it all the
time like reoccurring dreams really yeah
yeah that's a defense well if he's
caught really remember pretty excited by
it was all those things I used to wake
up really galvanized I want to start my
own company
really and it used to happen all the
time but when I say all the time I'm
talking about twice a week really
I'm telling you someone was telling you
very exactly and then and then basically
an offer come up to go and work for a
business that was doing a similar
industry to us yeah
but wanted to start a London operation
type thing you know they had a couple of
people on there but they were German
[ __ ] business and I was like sounds
like a fantastic opportunity on the
surface all it really really good it
just wasn't for me yeah just did my job
I shouldn't have done it
yeah in hindsight I should have done it
like a baby learn from those things
right I'll let the massive amount I'll
let the massive amount about because I
was sold for I think from a lot of the
the realities of running a business what
the previous had Jam yeah and
the business I went to for nine months I
started to understand you know more of
the BIM Boise Boise month cash flow yeah
that's one of the things isn't that when
when people start their own agency
they've just been billing normally that
whole time they never even had to think
about business so what so you've been
thinking about a lot but was there any
what was the driver behind like wanted
to start your own thing was it yeah was
any particular driver what why was that
why did you have a cousin it's not for
everyone right so oh yeah yeah like um I
think one like I I love my job and I do
love my job when I always love my job
even when I worked at the company that
wasn't for me I still love my job yeah
so I think it was part I think it was
partly that I think I the buildings I
was doing were very good and I was like
you know what I think I can really
really build a business out of this yes
which is good obviously the financial
benefits to come with that yeah I think
I wanted to make the company I've worked
out firstly didn't just the you
networking that frustrated me because
you wanted to really focus on your name
I wanted to be a trusted brand yeah you
know like if you want to go and buy a
Ferrari you don't go scored your idea
yeah and I go to Ferrari yeah and I
wanted to be a Ferrari top supply yeah
you need network engineers we really
wanted to double down on like I honest I
am your guy for this yeah like when you
think of like you know really really
trusted brands you know like you don't
say a vodka and energy drinks a vodka
ripple yeah because they are the go-to
people know you're on you look up their
branding around extreme sports and it's
perfect so right and that particularly
for me as I wanted to make a trusted
brand and I just don't I felt like the
time was right I could I was with my now
fiancé
you know duration Sarah recently and we
we were together and she was really my
rock okay and I felt like what you can't
do our job if you haven't got a good
personal life
I thought ruggle I think because it's
all like an even Nick knows always
talked about my Chi so like some days I
coming out to Kahana cheese not Ryan
let's go for a cup of tea lover and I
just that's going to sit like go down
the coffee shop have a cup of tea and
come back
alright cool I'm fine love that like and
I think having her really empowered me
if anything went absolutely tits up I've
got her on I'm sweet and it's yeah also
as well it's a lot to consider
we've been together now six years yeah
we never argue really ever you're lying
loads of the same interest yeah we're
constantly laughing all the time and we
really get on so like she's someone that
you can really lean on if you if it got
really bad and that's that and I think
because particular I think it's I don't
think many people talk about that in
that yeah because that's the thing I
think I don't think I could have done it
without her love that because you can't
because I think when you're at work or
then you know if you you know we have
some really stressful day yeah what bad
days yeah really bad it's good to then
be able to come home she doesn't share
first job ever was in recruitment okay
shaved on six months obviously she
doesn't work you did this ready war but
but I think it's important that when you
come home she's really not interested in
recruitment yeah which is perfect I love
that so it's because on I've got so I've
got so I'm in the house share yeah my
girlfriend here again there's actually
nothing about real criminal couldn't
agree more that helps massively yeah and
but I've moved so I connected we were
going on me that's London seven months
ago there's a guy called Tom Cotterill
and he's a recruiter he actually lives
on me so it's one of those things where
sometimes when I get home I am in the
mood to like talk about recruitment and
all what's going on but then sometimes
I'm like yeah I just I'm just not up for
it yeah they saw a hundred percent get
what you mean bit early and I think I
think that's great so I guess what what
was for people out there who will
definitely have certain fears around
stun on their own or they'll have that
voice in the head going now you can't do
it you can't do it like what what things
were going through your head or their I
don't know did you that you'd learn a
helmet now can do this like what what
was holding you back there actually when
you got on the other side is like wise
even thinking like that do you not I
mean was any particular things so I
think when we spoke you mentioned you
was quite young than you in like that
was a bit of a factor but I don't know
what was anything else that was really
going that you can't do you can't do
this number I was either 22 or 23 yeah
so I was young you know I think
particularly it was having Nick as well
so Nick background has been director
top top recruitment companies for you
know obviously either like okay I guess
I've heard this a few times maybe you
agree but if you have the opportunity to
do it with light another person the
light really feels right with less is
huge very very very very hard to do it
on your own yeah I think and I think
particularly Nick and I very young in
yang in the center
I'm very sales focused yeah I'm half his
age high for me to say that I look off
his IEG lose about half way and sorry
and I think that I think we balance out
you have a nicely because you've got age
which is perfect so when I'm being too
erratic too energetic you can include
probably much too aggressive he can do
that but then again on the flip side
then I can do the same with him if he's
not know become like no he's upped the
ante on this yeah so it works quite
nicely in that sense and I think from a
sales perspective I love going out with
new customers I love looking after the
customer he's still billing yeah yeah I
love it I can't help it yeah I should
have got off the tools a while ago just
hang in I love it too much yeah
massively Adam and Nick I think
particularly for the employees as well
we're like well like chalk and cheese if
you read like me you'll be like Nick are
taking more leaving you know type
different people but if you don't like
me which inevitably have people that are
on yeah they'll really like Nick and
Nick's very less important to have that
you think that's really help you uncle
Nick yeah yeah if you ever got a problem
go see uncle Nick like that you know the
amount of times that I've spoken to
people within my business and in other
business as well like just goes like
above and beyond extra mile like kind of
like coming to work last year and he was
doing somebody's mortgage application
for them really writing out the form
love that and that was like what you
doing this early is a mortgage
application but that's the thing I think
particularly because of the age of the
people that often we hire you mean you
need support man sort of work as well
you know it's not so good just going
yell you know basically we're just gonna
develop them and train them like you've
got help
stuff like moving out like Harry one of
the lights this book for years now he's
work for us yeah helped him move six
months ago really yeah bed up and put it
that low I think at the end of the day I
think whatever happens in his career
like he'll never forget that and I think
I mean I think for me when I saw I
joined a real small boutique agency and
I I sat next to my director the only the
business who build throughout all the
time I left and I think that I love that
so why if I was sat next to you and like
I get contact of you all down you
actually own the business you pay my
wages you pay my commission I just think
that I don't I love that I think this
really something powerful about feeling
valued and yeah especially in sales
because like when you when you do well
you get looked after that now one thing
on and to uncover because you mentioned
it sort of briefly was and like as we've
said there's there's some real bad days
in recruitment and you mentioned Chi
there and like what what have you done
this helped even as a business owner now
right when you have a real tough day
what would you tend to do so I meditate
every day yes yes love that I do look a
bit like the Buddha like I love that how
long that really that really helped me
so I've been meditating for about three
years now so all these breathing
exercises that's all it is yeah it's
just basically just so now and just
basically realizing there's more to life
than all the superficial stuff and just
chill out a bit love that yeah if it's a
bit the big misconception is that you
sit down and you don't think about
anything they're so far from what
happens all it is is that you you
basically it's absolutely fine to think
about work or think about some in random
but the most important thing is that you
then recognize that and you come back to
your breath yeah that's what meditation
is it's focusing on the breath and
coming back to that yeah so how has that
helped you in recruitment
yeah yeah massively so I think there's a
few things like people that know me and
work me know I'm very very very
structured and that I'm very process
orientated okay almost a robot really
potentially yeah but you wouldn't you
wouldn't think sometimes from
salespeople yeah but I think it's very
very important and like meditation as
part of that is particularly where I get
towards in the day
and I'm really really not you know ready
to go which is sometimes just likes just
calms you down yeah I do 10 15 minutes a
day every day I don't cross my legs
which is a common to sit down yeah just
to sit upright just chilling out your
office know right before the day starts
yeah no I don't know except a bit before
I fall asleep after work yeah so the
polymer solid I used to do it in the
morning because you get so relaxed
they're a nice comment so yeah I do it I
do it every evening unless I think I do
it between 6:45 and 10:00 p.m. but it
should be a lot that's more hesitation
so I really love that man how has that
helped how's that how has that helped
you as a recruitment business owner has
and as a recruiter but how long have you
meditating for what I was doing it on
and off
yeah for two three years I'll be doing
it solid now for a year
everyday so how does it hurt you then
let's talk about that what you feel
better okay I just feel better and I
think also as well so just to give you
an idea from a business perspective we
are seven months into our financial year
and we've hit our target already marker
and that was what we did last year we've
gone over what we did last year already
yeah yeah only with a slight increase in
head count or massive increase in head
count so I think it speaks volumes for
like the output that we've had here and
I think it's just helped me be a better
person just more chilled out and
particularly because I'm because I'm
very particular and because I Drive
really really high standards yeah you
get so uptight sometimes yeah I see
people don't see that but what it's done
it's just it's just helped me to
understand like there's more to life
than like worrying about so the way
somebody's prepped the CV hunters in I
think yeah what you're talking about
there's perspective right give me some
real perspective nothing for me and my
experience I think look when you're
having those really bad days and you've
got that kind of a he doesn't turn off
on that first day what meditation really
helped me with was the as the exercises
you got you you find yourself going
something then you come back to your
breath it helps you to take a step back
yeah and it's very easy in recruitment
because I've been and I've had those
days where the emotions get the better
of me because you're dealing with people
who didn't love with people's emotions
and person let me down like that it's
very easy to get carried away and I
think that that's what meditation will
help me because I've found it really
difficult if I'm honest at first when
people let me down his life would I do
that
yeah and then meditation really helped
me with that to be able to take a step
back and that again I've mentioned it a
lot but that will give you a competitive
advantage because why the best
recruiters will take that on the chin
and go again do not mean and just crack
on and it really helped with that so how
many what's the haircut now of eighteen
eighteen like oh cool
so how have you how has it been building
that taught the culture that you want to
you seem very positive and you care
about the people so what have you built
that and how have you got to sort of
eighteen because that's the 80% of the
recruitment industry employ up to nine
eight to ten people yeah so how have you
found that anywhere house because that's
a whole new challenge yeah of course it
is yeah I think we were only ever two
people leave which is good good terms or
yeah yeah one is good one for headhunted
by confirm by customer yeah Fona happen
happens here and one was commuting
ridiculous I wanted someone closer to
home work still work for us for years
blah blah so and I think so the biggest
thing for me is growing the business is
realizing I'm it's only a last year I've
realized is you can't do everything
yourself yeah
gone even though I speak and you can't
yeah so you can't do everything yourself
and I think it's hiring having a
stringent hiring process at the front
end okay that's a save you the pain
medium to long term yeah and then the
people that you do hire genuinely
believing that they're gonna be amazing
and really getting behind them okay type
things so I think when when we got to
like ten eleven people and this last
year roughly about eighteen months ago
yeah we hired we because we were like
Wyatt we've got loads of customers we
broke the back of the market we're doing
really really well
we thought we we panic har
hmm not loads of people to 3pj reaction
yeah and that was the thing it's almost
like we've got so much work on yeah need
to get people in enhanced opera voice
one of worse things we did so what did
you learn from that then interview a lot
hard luck yeah
production says but I did nothing I've
done so for the people we've just hired
so we've just hired and I hired one and
hi it's he before yeah
so the chat we've just hired Harry happy
birthday Harry birthday today today and
the the chap that we've just hired
before he did like 25 interviews really
hmm
so make some make them jump for a few
more hoops yes yeah and also as one it's
just like the so one of the best things
I actually started doing is getting our
trainees to interview people as well
really yeah so I'm a bit perspective as
the Oh first stage they spin oh he
speaks James over the telephone James
Dean then they come in potentially meet
Nick and James at the face then they'd
meet me and I'd be like Sam people are
yeah I'm like you somebody who's like
what asks I'm not just like your
qualifying candidates all that yeah
loves tell me how you feel and I think
also as well particularly what I send
them and we have once it's or hire
people they've always said yes because
they're like the trainees what they say
about the business
yeah like the chap that we did hire at
three or four fours elsewhere really I'm
not first job in recruiting and yeah I
think into you guys
well because yeah because nobody can be
a better advocate for what it's like to
join a company and work there in the
yeah I hope you get the people that have
been there six to nine months yeah no
100% nothing look I think look Peter of
course that's affected because someone
who's sitting there hasn't done
recruitment can see someone in front of
them that was in a similar shoes you
know I mean they're gonna connect with
that love that course so what a lot to
dive into is some some particulars about
billing and and being successful because
as you said you've you've always
consistently build and so you're at the
top of the room there calmly now James
is slightly ahead of it is it all
talking by a lot thankfully isn't he's
on holiday from really okay so okay the
first thing I'd like to ask because I
think you've got a good perspective now
mmm so how long has your business been
and going for another four years only
five four four and a half years love
that okay so what would you say is the
most common habit firstly the you see
that prevents people technics in the
next level what what would you say is
the lack of structure okay cool and then
is it would you say then the most common
habit you seen or people really excel is
its ham structure yeah yeah so the the
the best pillow that I worked with and a
never knew when I first have a joint Jam
many years ago we had a chap that worked
for us he's still meeting panel you're
on perm well mentor hmm but you don't
meet many of them I don't know anybody
else that so what was it we at brilliant
bright that down a bit then what was the
common things that you saw that I'm sure
you replicate or lack a woman or
literally went and he was faced in
Manchester I said to Nick I went can I
go and sit next to him for two weeks
really I'm a joined yeah love that so
I've been there about three four months
and I was like he's obviously the best
person in the business
yeah basically the rock man said yeah I
go sit next to him you saw them that's
interesting right so a few things he
said that really really stuck with me
okay phrases and yeah he said so firstly
you'd never knows the top pillar move so
yeah but you always say that yeah yeah
sorry you might people have these image
this image of top pillars wearing
pinstripes so yeah shiny shoes yes and
red ties and yes off they're usually the
the okay palace right if they that I
think they're because I think they're
diner because they're spending all their
money on the pinstripes exactly so the
chap that the chap that was the top
biller
married age-wise 29 maybe 30 okay
two kids lived in a talk to you down in
Manchester yeah driver nice car for
drive yeah Volkswagen car yeah he used
to dress very unassumingly but very
smart yeah
very pleasant yeah always always like
one of these people when a new person
would join he'd walk over to the office
a big office 100 people in there yeah
and he goes sit down with regards
like if you need anything can pop over
come and ask me and he was the only
person that you never ever heard on the
phone because he used to sit his desk
and just God oh how are you how's things
like he's really he had a very calming
tone about him and he was just not what
you would expect at all he's still there
now and um and I think more than
anything something he said that really
really resonated with me said he's not
he's not amazing
he was like I'm just like good every day
I'm not very good consistent I'm not
fantastic but he was a lot of people
he's worked with if he's like they're
amazing on Monday Tuesday like they're
really good Wednesday they go out get
pissed yeah at first they can't do any
work yeah and then Friday they kind of
bumble through it wait and he's out
don't do only that he was like I come in
I just do the same thing every single
day mm-hmm and it works so then that was
that humility he had yeah and
consistency consistency there and that
was the thing it was like consistency he
was like if you do if you get the basics
right yeah I know my people leave her in
this as well yeah from a recruitment
aviva myself the guys don't do anything
groundbreaking yeah but we just do the
basics really well every day yeah and
you have to do them really well every
doubt if you do them really well every
day you do anything for five or 10 years
you come get it yeah of course
okay so as we were looking before one of
the questions that someone wanted me to
ask which goes along with this is like
as you see you've been on co-taught
Villa and and a successful one so what
how does what is your structure they
look like because all I should structure
Monday and it had a serious impact on
Billings and what I doing for sure so
how do you structure your day that has
been a real great structure that served
you well
so well I'm an early riser yep something
the office usually up half 6:00 yeah
quarter to 7:00 yeah which is pretty
savage but I love it this I like it it's
all because particular I think the rush
to work I don't get involved in that
yeah yeah like I mean everything's calm
particularly I work we work in the city
and it's so calm in the morning and
we'll get your coffee get your breakfast
go to the office and then what would you
do in those first few hours oh yeah so
particularly any email legwork any
prepper
should say admin yeah I'd mean that kind
of stuff I'd say when when you hit half
a you wants to spend half eight to a
half five on the phone yeah and any
preparation to make you do that is ready
- I come in - by the time I start half a
I've got any emails my box really action
done okay so okay so I'm so half at
you'd in admin emails prep all that man
and what and then he said phone rest day
but do you strict like do you block out
time for be deed you block out time for
connect sourcing what would you do so
half a half eight to nine is the morning
meeting okay and what that is is
basically we go around the whole room
you have 30 seconds to a minute to say
what went well yesterday what didn't a
lot of anybody's got any advice love
that which is really important I think I
really like that because people don't
get time to talk together and in
particular as the office gets bigger and
bigger there might be somebody down the
end of the office it's got a great idea
to help you out the problem contour
class yeah I so and then once the day
kicks off if what so if I was a
consultant yeah there in 360 what they
slightly different now because know me
here let's talk that perspective talk
from that perspective I first and
foremost will spend the first half an
hour chasing up clients interviews CV
feedback okay all my jobs yeah and even
the jobs that even the ones that haven't
feedback on any views whatever I'll ring
them just to let you know that we're
still working it yeah you know I just
wanted to let you know nice cuz I don't
think you should leave clients in the
doll good press and then what I'll do is
officer that I would then spend sourcing
a half nine till during the source in
time I turn my emails off I was gonna
say do you yeah I turned he not off
because we are database basically emails
through so we have a cloud-based CRM
yeah and if you want to email anybody
you can do it through the CRM love that
sort of thing so I turn your mouse off
then to their Rd sourcing in the morning
because you've changed your clients all
morning and then also because I'm a big
believer in if you don't get hold of the
candidate you're trying to get hold off
if they don't got the rest of the day to
get back to you you know which is good
yeah so you did out to what like midday
yeah typically typically half 11 yeah
I'll do that too then
and then I'll write where I'm up to turn
emails back on yeah stop sourcing for
the next half an hour yeah and respond
to any emails that have come in or
anything I needs to do quickly or return
calls
yeah or whatever and then also as well
yeah a big one for me I don't ever have
my mobile phone on me really ever so if
anybody needs to get hold me don't ring
your while okay my landline okay just
because it's sorry if you say that to
concerns as well in terms of like
because looking something up or use
their mobile to reincarnates and stuff
so would you rather than use the
landline
we don't know like so the first come
have a work for you to have like a
withheld number that's that's I don't I
think particularly us ours is a landline
number based in London
yeah gonna pick it up if not already
checks her voicemails yeah if there's so
many particularly struggling to get hold
up I'm like going get my phone and
whatsapp them yeah whatever yeah but I
think fraud mosasaur consultants don't
have their phones on them either
it's because I'm kind of on the phone so
you're at midday now I'm at midday now
so I have lunch everyday at 12 o'clock
yep periodic because obviously I'm in
the office is six yes yeah and I usually
try and get away from my desk because
somebody ought sofas and I'll sit
anymore lunch for 15-20 minutes yeah
type thing yeah bring my lunch to work
just cuz going out spending money on a
sandwich of course you're 12 quid yeah I
agree I've always been that type of
person as oh yeah yeah yeah
Tupperware and meal prep and then
basically yeah then spending the next
half an hour doing some more wrapping if
any moment hits one o'clock business
development really it's the rest of day
yeah really
there's always business what needs to be
done yeah and I think to do more
business development and candidates yeah
really interesting yeah cuz I'm gonna
start I start can it look after our five
again uh okay so people finish work ok
so then and then BD yeah so one two yeah
the end of the day do you have line
admin break again in between or no not
in between from the end of at the end of
it at the end of our for summer yeah
and then and then you're back hitting
the finds for candidates after trying to
hit them after work when obviously I
guess if you got some roles which you
know would be great if you could feel
you'd stay to whatever time but yeah
what I always used to promise myself is
Tuesdays and Thursdays I would stay till
half seven love that
so you haven't even structure around
that way dedicate fair enough that's
gettin ugly and then I'd worked all half
six Monday Wednesday and Fridays we
should be finished at four anyway yeah I
really like that yeah fair enough that's
all let's say one quick question around
that and we'll start wrapping up but and
I'm sure there's a lot of people out
there who have the perfect structure but
they really find it hard to stick to it
what advice would you say has helped you
stick to your structure besides you have
to have an element of discipline and
stick to it but there's obviously we can
get distracted very easily today in
today's world right so is there been
anything that you've solved tweets or
changed in the last couple years that
have really helped stick to that turn
your emails off yeah in the sighs well
that LinkedIn sees to scroll through
that these days shut it and then anybody
that because obviously will do LinkedIn
work but that would be more out of hours
more yeah for me I think I think
LinkedIn sourcing people for LinkedIn
for me he's always been a last resort
because it's a lot of legwork
I mean it's time-consuming you I can
tell you'd want to speak to humans and
yeah under Sam yeah when I had to lie
dedicate like two hours to like in mouth
and laugh and it's so difficult because
I'll just LA yeah I'll just copy and
paste messages that shine
yeah well that's that's the thing that's
what 95% of people do though yeah and
and the people that don't spend four
four hours on it yeah and then it's like
a day it's like you know what you might
you might get that really really top top
person yeah but it's a lot of investment
and you're rolling the dice every time
you do that yeah you only get 20 working
days in a month
yeah the best way to think of I was
thinking like credits yeah would you
spend one of your credits people not to
get anything clear lover solid Matt so
I'm at so yeah cool okay so last
question before I ask you the final
question which always asks everyone and
there again it was one of the questions
and people wanted me to ask as a
business owner what work because there's
so much recruitment tech out there
yesterday and I'm sure you get sales
pitches most days
what what's been them your favorite
favorite piece of tech for your
recruitment business it's had a real
positive impact telephone and I'm joking
that helps favor us actually a really
really good question don't have to be
one if there's like two other mind
source breakers good okay yeah Steve
Beckett if you listen you know I might
yes I saw break off I was really really
good good business I think that's been
particularly the concepts of it's pretty
simple okay but the way that they've the
way they've executed is very good so
that's had an impact on your own
business that you've liked yeah okay
yeah on the percent and the for now so
I'll just that anything else that I've
been impressed with from a tip if I told
you all the technology use I'll be given
all the secrets like anything that it's
like you've cuz let as I said like
recruitment business owners will be
getting sold a lot you know i mean ii
Fitness had a real positive impact if
it's just saw spray no but if there's
the to be fair that the database company
we use community and always very good
always them the serum that we had yeah
yes I am so you right then they've
helped a lot obviously better than
bullhorn really mmm interesting cool
okay so and right so before actually the
last question what's and what's going on
in your world make that you're excited
about what's going on in Hamilton bonds
that you want to shout about we're doing
we've got Cisco live at the end of the
month which is gonna be Chloe and all
the team of going and that's gonna be
basically loads of networking logo
drinking I'm built for it so that's
that's good we're doing our charity run
in May where we're gonna be running
around the Tower of London okay around
the tower alone wolf so I'll be Samantha
no why should they
but I'm living what I'm always working
yeah yeah so we've got we've got we've
got all our 10k yeah in Maine it's
coming up in ISO and we're currently
looking next holiday incentive which is
gonna be in Croatia special Corps good
nice allegedly and then next year conch
with us really and against the US market
yeah love that money in it but we're
gonna we're gonna guys in terms a lot
have people on the ground there love
that and cool so the question I always
ask people mate it's the last question
you can answer it with a sentence a
phrase it can be whatever you want it to
be but if if you could communicate to
every single recruiter out there and
they'd listen to George their take on
your your advice what would you say
treat your candidate with respect yeah
simple mate that's a simple take care of
you candidates clients will come yeah
love that no it's been an absolute
pleasure mate that's all right thanks
your time thank you very much nice to
coming in just soft cheese